the wave of new cases in europe is
forcing france and germany to go
back into lockdown france's president
said last night
the new spike would be harder and
deadlier than the first
germany's chancellor said this morning
that the country's hospitals could be
overwhelmed in a few weeks elizabeth
palmer has more
enjoying the last few hours of freedom
with friends
parisians watched their president
deliver the bad news
emmanuel macron told the country a new
lockdown had to be a brutal break on
rocketing covet infections as of
midnight tonight
bars restaurants and non-essential
businesses will close until december
those schools and factories will stay
open
but police will check that anyone out on
the street has a good reason to leave
home
planes have been flying severely ill
patients to hospitals in other parts of
france that can
take them and more than half of
intensive care beds are already full
in barcelona restaurant workers
protested against
closures in spain that have thrown many
of them out of work
but there's no chance european leaders
can ease restrictions now with more than
a million new infections over the last
week that's nearly half of all new cases
on earth even germany where masks and
above all
efficient testing had kept the infection
rate low
is risking losing control for the first
time
a partial lockdown there will close
restaurants
bars and movie theaters until december
now here in the uk large areas are
already under very strict lock down
but the infection seems to be
skyrocketing anyway so scientists and
even some politicians are saying the
only thing that's going to slow it down
is a national lockdown anthony very
discouraging